you don't be amazing like day one Elon
gets the company it converts into a
blockchain and then Twitter removes
itself from any moderation capabilities
it becomes a totally decentralized
networking tool
so it's just like We Can't Ban anybody
anymore or he just buys it and deletes
it for the benefit of the world off
could he could he buy it and then like
free like free soft make all the code
free well he should and we should heal
but we need the version history so that
we can see all the algorithm changes
that they made punishing people over the
years that those are the skeletons that
are in the closet because every code
change in git there's a version history
so you can see oh they started punishing
this type of content on this date in you
know the election season and you know
that that data exists and like it needs
to be audited can they scrub version
histories not easily but they can
um
I don't I think that would be
unlikely I think that if he if he open
sources the code he said he was going to
open source it so hopefully he does so
so real quick real quick this is
important if Elon Musk does finalize his
bite of this company he's gonna have
logs showing that Twitter was targeting
conservatives or people on the right yes
it's funny because uh they it's the
weirdest thing Gizmodo publishes the
story Facebook censoring conservative
news outlets I then go hey everybody wow
that's crazy look Facebook censoring
then I get smeared as pushing conspiracy
theories for believing what Gizmodo
publishes it's going to be very
vindicating for everybody if Elon Musk
does do this so I certainly hope he does
but I have to wonder as well
I I think what's going to come out of
Twitter's closet is going to be more
than skeletons there's going to be some
real dark stuff we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna we'll probably see internal
Communications of them defending child
abusers and explaining why this you know
what I mean well this is gonna get
complicated because Elon is gonna have a
tough decision to make because he now is
responsible for this company and the
financial success of this this is why he
wants to take a private which makes
sense because he will have a fiduciary
duty to potentially not share a lot of
the skeletons which could get dicey so
Bill if I could ask you you have a lot
of history with social media obviously
with Minds if you were Elon Musk what
would you do right now
I mean I think he's doing what he can I
think he's he's like he's trying not to
buy it yeah yeah yeah but let's say the
the acquisition finally goes through you
have Twitter what would you do if you
were Elon with Twitter you immediately
open source all the code
you immediately make all the messages
and 10 encrypted so thousands of Twitter
employees can't read our messages it's
just like so absurd Facebook edit and
encryption no WhatsApp says they did or
the Saudi government can't read
protesters private DMS and messages of
Human Rights activists like he did
before Twitter I got a question do you
think that Twitter receives money from
governments to allow them backdoors
I think that it is I I don't know
Verizon does at T does right so so I
think there's a strong possibility
the one of the reasons Elon may have
backed out
is he may have gone to Twitter and says
I want to buy the company and they went
here are the lucrative contracts keeping
the company afloat that you can never
reveal because governments are paying
for back doors and you can't reveal
those and then Elon went crap it might
not just be contracts it might be just
threats and do rest of the government
saying we're going to shut you down or
we're going to make sure you can't do
business if you don't do what you want
well that's 100 and then and then like
15 years ago we were reporting on
specific stories of the NSA of the
federal government having their own
office spaces inside of the headquarters
of Verizon a t T-Mobile the major cell
phone providers in this country had
entire floors dedicated to the federal
government that was spying and watching
on everyone what what's Twitter what's
Twitter involved in it's like it's like
that movie The Santa Claus with Tim
Allen how like being Santa is actually a
curse you guys know what I'm talking
about right like Santa's on his roof and
then Tim Allen kills the guy and then
steals his clothes and for some reason
puts them on and then becomes Santa and
loses his family and then it's like a
mind virus that makes him happy about it
right now I'm and I am someone being
cute but no what I mean is Elon Musk or
anybody it feels like he goes to Twitter
and they're like no no no no don't buy
this company don't buy this company and
then finally they're like okay buy the
company and now they're looking at this
like we are going to get paid to leave
and not have to be involved in this
behind the scenes National Security BS I
I would bet I if if here's a way I'll
play it if I went to a casino and I saw
Blackjack roulette and do you think the
net that the US government has national
security letters onto Twitter demanding
back doors I would put all my money on
that I'm not playing another game
because that's a Sure Shot Elon Musk
comes in asks them like okay show me
corporate documents and he's got an NDA
and not only that but a national
security letter with a gag order from
the government and he went
crap and they're like you can't say
anything about it you have to buy it and
if and when you do buy it you won't be
able to do anything you want to do
because they will force you to give them
the back doors and we already saw the
White House going to Facebook and saying
ban these people there is a zero percent
chance they they did not do that with
Twitter and Elon probably saw that yeah
it's not just a back door to the
information I think it's even more than
that I think it's deciding who gets
censored deciding which voices get
downranked in the algorithm I think the
federal government is way more involved
not just with of course the intelligence
agencies helping give a lot of these big
Tech social media companies their start
but but what do you think of this
running your own social media Network
what's the possibility of what me and
Tim are talking about
yeah very likely I mean well we saw the
Alex Berenson all this these Discovery
documents came out recently between
Twitter and the White House where Alex
Berenson got banned from Twitter and
sued them exactly it's the slack
conversation of the Twitter employees
saying oh you know I forget the guy's
name at the White House said why is Alex
Berenson still on the platform so to
amend my earlier statement when I said
that's a zero percent chance no actually
the evidence already been released by
Alex Berenson yeah yeah and then the the
the the the the thing I was pointing to
is when they were talking about
Instagram I think when the White House
was like Hey this one's not ours can you
do something about it it was the Anthony
fauci parody
so we know the government they're doing
the wink wink nudge nudge yeah and I
think worse than that obviously but I'm
I'm wondering if say this Saudis they go
to Twitter and say how much will it cost
to get access to your to your back end
to your to get back doors Twitter needs
money
I think it's possible for Elon to switch
past but he's gonna have to start
playing Hardball with major countries
and risking Twitter getting banned in
those countries if he doesn't play ball
you know it's it's a marketing dream for
com you know SpaceX and Tesla to have
Twitter as a you know marketing engine
for those companies so you know it makes
a lot of sense for Elon it's a question
of in order to do this Elon has to get
Banks to back it money has to come from
somewhere and no one is willing to pay
full the full price to take the platform
and then just convert it into a
blockchain open source decentralized
network if that were to happen You Can't
Ban anybody ever again you know they can
co-exist though like you can have a
centralized infrastructure and a
decentralized infrastructure running in
parallel we actually just integrated
with a new network called Noster which
stands for notes and other stuff
transmitted by relay it is a there's
relays all over the world everybody has
a crypto key pair that we don't have
access to his Minds that's your identity
you can bring your followers and your
content and log into other apps you can
leave you can leave us it's not a
blockchain but it's a distributed system
so you know there's and there's other
projects out there that are like this
you've got the fediverse you've got
activity pup you've got uh farcaster is
the new one you've got planetary you've
got secure scuttlebutt there's all these
protocols that are like in the mix and
Twitter can integrate and Facebook and
all Rumble other networks I'm trying to
we're going to talk with them about
integrating like we can all join these
from open product yeah we can get all of
the alternative Tech sites to join as
well so we're all participating but that
doesn't mean you have to abandon the
existing infrastructure as well they can
run in parallel and Elon did express
interest in working with Rumble uh so I
think that also is is giving a lot of
people optimism but but as we're talking
about here Twitter is a major Powerhouse
Twitter is is a vector of influence that
a lot of powerful governments need and
want in their fingertips and it would be
foolish to think that their fingertips
and fingers and hands aren't already in
this larger influence that Twitter and
big Tech social media has just uh in
2019 there was an ex Twitter employee
that was found guilty for spying for the
Saudi government specifically going
through private messages going after
dissidents of the Saudi Empire and
sharing that information directly with
Muhammad bin Salman so so again that's
just one example Twitter's Revenue model
is Twitter's addicted to surveillance
advertising just like Facebook and so
Elon needs to rip that out you know Elon
knows how to make money he knows how to
make people people pay like you know 50
to 100K for a car like he has some of
the most profitable you know money
making machines in the world
he can figure out how to make Twitter
way more profitable without doing all
the nonsense I it is possible yeah you
do something like super Minds yeah where
like you could send somebody an offer
and then they can accept the offer to
respond so back to back to the question
because we cut you off really quickly
this one you were going back to this
yeah let's talk more about this you were
Elon Ian Ian feel free to jump in on
this if you're Elon as well you have
Twitter what do you do that's my
question you said he open source
everything yeah do you so would that
reinstate everybody obviously when you
say open source you mean agpl3 like a
free like there's another license
there's multiple licenses that that
could work I hope that he actually does
it because I remember when all those
news came out about oh Tesla's open
sourcing their batteries remember yeah
yeah that was not real that was that he
he just decided not to be a patent troll
he decided to sort of open the patent so
he wasn't going to go around suing other
competitors in the general space but
like the code of you know the software
running on Tesla is the battery
blueprints none of that is is open
source yeah so the difference between a
lot of the cars is just the software
yeah that you're paying for that's not
open source yeah the same software that
is running the AI on on the new
um you know Tesla Bots is the same is
what's running in the car it's the same
system I got an idea
so we're talking to this uh this uh
fabricator metal fabricator guy about
building a one-of-a-kind unique electric
car we should do it with mines it should
be powered by mines so like your your
digital console is like a mines console
oh yeah because you need an operating
system right and an app within the so
let's do it yeah so uh we can do it
really we were talking we can make like
a really cheap electric car and I was
like as a gag we have like a 2006 Cobalt
with 230 000 miles on it and I was like
yeah let's do that and not fix anything
and be like boom one of a kind uh or we
could actually make a really cool car
like actually works and everything we
should have it like integrate with mines
let's do it I I saw some there's some
amazing like refurbishing companies that
can take like any car and just make an
electric car like there's this one uh
page on uh I forget it's it's they
take Volkswagen specifically and they'll
make it any Volkswagen electric from any
period of time I'm gonna make the
Flintstone car and beat all of you guys
including Tesla when the EMP goes off
and nuclear Armageddon happens but will
you run now no no like the funny thing
with the Flintstones car is like pedals
exist we've discovered that quite a bit
uh quite a long time ago yeah but it
doesn't look as funny in the cartoons
when you're pedaling when you're yeah
you ever see those cars where there's
there's two sets of pedals in the front
in the back and everyone in the car is
pedaling and it's going there you go man
I was just going to say that I
did ask uh we we sent a message to Elon
asking this question I don't know if if
he'll answer it but
there needs to be a Tesla that is not
subject to just getting shut down from
Tesla HQ like you're talking about like
like I could see him getting behind that
like a Tesla that's Sovereign and like
the software's running locally so that
it's just not like sketchy dystopian
possibility but do you know that um I'm
not sure Luke if you know this some of
them have cameras pointing at you the
driver and if you aren't paying
attention or something it alerts you and
it records that it uses it against you
that is nightmares it has that history
too yeah yeah because I because uh I saw
in the console of the model S there's a
camera and I was like is that I Googled
it I'm like is that's cool like because
you know Uber drivers for instance they
turn cameras on to film their passengers
and I'm like that could be helpful if
there's a car accident if you're side
swept or something you have no access to
that camera it is for them to spy on you
as you drive creepy so there's no
obviously you can't log into your Tesla
account and check out yeah like what
data is Maybe I'm Wrong Maybe I'm Wrong
Maybe I'm wrong I don't know I doubt
that they give you access to all the the
footage of but you think no no no no so
the side cameras you can't like oh yeah
so I can pull up my phone right now and
look at my car in the garage the model
three yeah yeah that's really cool like
but there's an internal camera and I'm
like what is that all about the CIA has
access to all of it live as it's going
on uh most likely uh without it without
a doubt the NSA yeah there's no way that
they don't so you know I I you know I
would automatically tape up that camera
as fast as I can uh but I heard some car
manufacturers take away your ability to
do self-driving if you cover up that
camera because the cameras are focused
on your eyes to make sure that your eyes
are focused on the road and if your eyes
and hands aren't focused on on the road
and the wheel they stop automatic
driving and make you drive instead of
having the car drive you you guys know
that basically like all new cars are
self-driving so Tesla has full
self-driving capability only after your
car has driven on the highway on
autopilot for 100 miles you have a high
safety score and they approve you so my
model 3 apparently just got recently
like congratulations it's now entitled
to full self-driving and that's where
the car will actually stop at the stop
sign check and then slowly turn right in
the steering wheel spinning by itself
but most of them when people think of
like oh the Teslas can drive themselves
and then you get in the Tesla for the
first time and you're like autopilot and
you're like wow all it does is just the
steering wheel moves a little bit left
and right on the highway that's it it'll
speed up slow down
and then I so when I first saw that when
I got the model three I was like whoa
this is crazy I'm like I'm on the
highway and like it's moving itself then
I got out then I got a Honda
it's got the same thing huh modern Honda
is the exact same thing no difference
it's it's Auto steer and cruise control
so I'm on the highway and I'm like oh
that's what they call it auto steer it's
called something like Lane correction or
something like that I don't know but
it's it's it so the Honda can't activate
a full self drive like the Tesla can but
Teslas don't come with that anyway you
have to earn a special pilot you know a
beta or something could Honda run of
self-driving upgrade probably remotely I
have to imagine if they can drive
themselves on the highway they can drive
themselves in the streets so I don't
know I think the Teslas don't use sonar
anymore or radar or something like that
and it switched to just camera and I
noticed this because I think when they
switched it it got way worse
it like doesn't understand what's going
on anymore and I I wonder why maybe
statistically the radar Persona or
whatever it was was worse and now like
cameras are better but then if you get
like Schmutz on the on the camera or
something then it just turns off on you
I was driving in the rain and I have it
on on self-drive autopilot on the
highway and it's I'm going 70 miles an
hour and it's making a turn and then we
get close to a semi and it goes boom
boom it just turns off and I'm like what
the like that's scary you keep your
hands on the wheel the whole time but
when so you're going with it when it
stops just like whoa this is
self-driving it sounds tragedy waiting
to happen man that people they encourage
you to take your hands off the wheel
how is that going to make you more
attention
so they want you to be sitting there
like a zombie but still somehow be more
like you're gonna become less attentive
to what's going on if you're not
actually supposed to be attending to it
how can that be good thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there